les mouvements des plaques tectoniques
pour les élèves de troisième année du
collège la berrière poursuivre
pleinement cette vidéo le syllabus de
géographie le manuel l'attitude
troisième notamment les pages 193 et 194
ainsi que votre place les planches
géologie concernant la terre aux
planches 190 293 la terre est composé de
plusieurs couches depuis son noyau
jusqu'à les corses terrestre les deux
couches extérieures sont la lithosphère
et l'asthénosphère la lithosphère et
rigide
elle est constituée de la croûte et de
la partie supérieure du manteau
c'est tout ça la lithosphère
l'asthénosphère quant à elle est située
entre cette croûte et le manteau
inférieur à ces noces faire est ici
l'article
faire n'est pas totalement solide comme
la lithosphère elle est plutôt visqueuse
et elle est également plus chaude que la
croûte et que la lithosphère vous voyez
en effet que le noyau est beaucoup plus
chaud et plus que je peux plus je
m'écarte de ce noyau plus la température
chute
cet écart de température va créer des
mouvements de convection qui sont en
fait des boucles formé par la matière
chaude qui monte et qui descend ça monte
et ça descend
c'est un petit peu comme dans une
casserole si vous faites bouillir de
l'eau chaude l'eau va monter et puis une
fois la surface elle se refroidit elle
retombe sur les côtés les mouvements de
convection du magma à l'intérieur de la
sténo sphère vont exercer des pressions
sur la lithosphère qui est rigide la
lithosphère et la croûte terrestre vont
se casser et formes et différentes
plaques
les plaques tectoniques ces différentes
plaques vont en raison des moins de
conviction qui créé différentes forces
vont bouger dans différentes directions
dans différents mouvements qu'on appelle
les mouvements tectoniques
les premiers mouvements que nous allons
étudier ce sont les mouvements de
divergence c'est à dire que c'est ce
sont deux plaques qui s'écartent l'une
de l'autre
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer avait
il va se passer qu'on va avoir
l'apparition comme ici voyez d'une
dorsale c'est quoi une dorsale
c'est un relief au milieu de l'océan
parce qu'en fait entre la dorsale au
milieu de la dorsale il ya un risque
voyez ici je repasse et bien en fait
c'est vraiment là la zone où les plaques
ces cartes ici j'ai une première plaque
et ici j'ai une seconde plaque mais qui
s'écartent l'une de l'autre
ça va former du nouveau plancher
océanique en fait on a de vraiment de la
croûte océanique ici qui se créent force
que les plaques ses cartes
alors c'est souvent au milieu d'un océan
mais ça a peut être au milieu de terre
il ya deux endroits au monde où en un
rift comme on appelle ça c'est en
afrique en afrique de l'ouest et en
islande ici vous avez le rift africain
et vous voyez
on a vraiment l'écartement d'une plaque
d'un côté et les autres plaques qui va
de l'autre côté
ensuite on peut avoir un mouvement de
convergence
ce sont deux plaques qui se rapproche
cette fois ci alors pour les mouvements
de convergence on a deux possibilités on
peut être dans un mouvement de
subduction qu'est ce que ça veut dire
j'ai d'un côté une plaque océanique qui
est plus lourde qui va passer en dessous
d'une plaque continentale qui est plus
légère elle plus lent et moins dans ses
traditions légèreté c'est une question
de densité
nokelainen qui passent en dessous de
l'autre la plaque océanique en passant
en dessous va exercer des pressions sur
le magma va fragiliser la plaque
continentale ici et qu'est ce que je
vais avoir je veux avoir une remontée de
magma qui va former un volcan le magma
la sortie finalement je vais avoir
l'apparition ici d'un archipel
volcanique donc d'un arc volcanique
c'est à dire tout plein de petites îles
qui sont des volcans en fait en plus de
ça ici j'ai eu une zone très profondes
qu'on va appeler une fosse océanique
c'est vraiment une zone très très
profonde puisque la plaque en descendant
la plaque océanique en descendant à
vraiment creuser un creux au fond des
océans toujours un mouvement de
convergence donc c'est un ce sont des
plaques qui se rapproche mais ici ce
sont deux plaques continentales et elles
vont engendrer une collision
il y en a aucune qui va céder sur
l'autre puisqu'elles ont la même densité
et finalement elles vont monter elles
vont monter et elles vont forte pour
former des montagnes c'est comme ça que
se créent les montagnes attention qu'on
voit toujours cette image comme celle ci
les montagnes en eau mais la plaque en
fait al s'épaissit également bas dans
votre manuel vous avez un très bon
graphique qui vous représente ça
vraiment on a vraiment tout une
épaisseur ici qui est formé par la
collision des deux claques dern
mouvement on peut imaginer que deux
plaques vont se décroche et elles vont
coulisser l'une par rapport à l'autre
alors vous voyez ici on a une première
possibilité via une plaque qui part
comme ça les autres qui part comme ça il
y en a une qui part plus en profondeur
et l'autre qui se soulèvent ou
inversément dents sur le terrain qu'est
ce que ça va donner
ben je veux avoir la déformation de
route ou ici voyez les rails du chemin
de fer qui sont totalement déformés en
fait j'ai une plaque qui va d'un côté et
l'autre qui va de l'autre donc dès lors
ça ça des vies le cours des routes et le
courroux des chemins de fer évidemment
sa cause du dga pour toutes les
infrastructures humaines si on
récapitule tout depuis le début
donc j'ai différentes zones des zones de
divergences et des zones de convergence
ainsi que des zones de décrochement qui
vont donner naissance à différents
mouvements dans une zone divergent sur
un écartement dans les zones de
convergence d'une subduction où une
collision dans la zone de décrochement
j'aurai un coulissage alors les
conséquences quelles sont-elles pour les
cartes mangera dorsales océaniques et un
rift je vais pour avoir avoir pour la
zone de subduction une fosse marine et
un arc volcaniques pour la collision des
montagnes et pour le polissage ce sont
des failles transformante l'exposé
terminé passons aux consignes de la
préparation réalisée pour le prochain
cours tout d'abord je vous demande et
d'analyser une zone de mouvements
tectoniques et ses conséquences
d'abord vous devrez choisir une limite
entre deux plaques tectoniques n'importe
laquelle
un exemple vous est donné ici après les
consignes vous localiseraient de façon
absolue grâce aux coordonnées
coordonnées géographiques la limite des
plaques que vous avez choisi vous
définirez le mouvement de cette zone est
ce qu'on est dans une zone de divergence
une zone de convergence avait plutôt une
subduction où une collision
ou alors est-ce qu'on est dans une zone
de décrochement et puis vous analyserez
les conséquences à partir d'une carte
oro hydrographique
pour réaliser cette préparation vous
avez besoin de votre
là ce qui vous permettra d'avoir la
carte des plaques tectoniques ainsi
qu'une carte oro hydrographique pour
rappel une carte euros hydrographique
c'est comme une carte comme celle que
j'ai mis dans vos classes où vous avez à
la fois le relief et tous les cours
d'eau
vous aurez besoin de votre manuel pour
toute la théorie et cette vidéo
évidemment vous permet de comprendre ce
qu'est la tectonique des plaques
ce que vous devez faire au final c'est
compléter le formulaire qui est sur blu
géo en dessous de la vidéo
évidemment si c'est pas fait c'est
sanctionner
concrètement qu'est ce que je dois faire
pour la préparation
je dois tout d'abord prendre ces deux
cartes qui sont dans votre place en tout
cas vous prenez la carte la tectonique
des plaques qui est ici 192 b dans la
14e édition de grand atlas de chez de
bouc et vous prenez éventuellement la
carte du montoro hydrographique qui
reprend l'ensemble du mouvement jeune
hémicycle amérique du nord parce que je
vais et l'amérique centrale parce que je
vais me consacrer après l'exemple à
cette partie alors je vais choisir au
hasard ou par contre c'est comme vous
voulez une limite entre deux plaques
voyez moi je vais prendre ici la limite
entre la plaque de coco et la plaque des
caraïbes
voyez ici je suis serein car il ya une
limite ici c'est ça je vais m'intéresser
à sa première chose à faire il faut que
j'ai choisi cette plaque je vais la
localiser sur ma planche oro
hydrographique alors je vois que je suis
au niveau de l'amérique centrale
ma plaquette ici pas la limite entre les
deux plaques est ici d'accord plus ou
moins ça je fais le travail mentalement
alors je ne posais la question de savoir
déjà sur quel localisation je me trouve
je vais regarder ma latitude et la
longitude alors ici je suis plus ou
moins cinq degrés de latitude nord et je
vais jusque plus ou moins 17 16 17
il faut pas être précis vous devez pas
mesuré vous devez juste regarder en gros
où vous vous situez et au niveau de la
longitude je suis à 80
ici de longitude ouest jusque je remonte
et je remonte avec vous jusque 100 donc
voilà première partie d'exercice je note
sur ma feuille la latitude et la
longitude des limites de ma plaque
après je les en cause ray dans le
formulaire évidemment deuxième chose je
dois me poser la question je suis face à
quel mouvement de plaques vous voyez qu
ici il ya deux flèches qui se rapproche
bien c'est une zone de convergence alors
est ce que je suis dans une zone de
subduction où on dans une zone de
collision
eh bien ça je vais regarder simplement
ce que j'ai sur ma carte oro
hydrographiques et je vois qu'à ce
niveau aussi voyez j'ai des petits ronds
et des petits triangles
en fait dans la légende de cette carte
on va voir que le petit triangle ce sont
des volcans et les petits ronds ce sont
deux tremblements de terre
et ici j'ai une bande de bleus je leur
passé en bleu qui est un peu plus foncée
voyez j'en passe dessus quand je vais
voir dans la légende du relief je vois
que c'est une zone plus profonde donc
c'est une fausse les fausses
généralement elles sont beaucoup plus
foncé sur les cartes géographiques que
les endroits où il n'ya pas de fausses
donc j'ai une fausse j'ai des volcans je
suis je peux faire l'hypothèse que je
suis face à une zone de subduction donc
c'est à dire que la plaque ici
continental la plaque océanique pardon
va passer en dessous de la plaque
continentale d'accord voilà bon bien sûr
je sais pas sûr à 100% mais voilà avec
les éléments que j'ai c'est ma
conclusion qu'est ce que je vais mettre
sur mon formulaire bon ben je vais
encore des mamies coordonnées
géographiques
je vais mettre que je suis dans une zone
de convergence plus précisément une zone
de subduction et qu'est ce que j'observe
j'observe la présence d'une fosse marine
au niveau de l'amérique centrale voyais
amérique centrale j'utilise des repères
géographiques
je remarque que j'ai à partir de panama
toute une série de volcans il faut bien
citer panama pour bien me montrer que
vous avez bien vu où ça se trouvait et
j'ai aussi quelques volcan près de
mexico
on les utilise les éléments qui me sont
donnés par mme acker je pourrais
éventuellement mais ça c'est ce qu'on
verra en classe dire qu'il ya des
tremblements de terre qui sont liées à
ce mouvement de plaques tectoniques
on est en vie tout ça moi j'ai fait une
préparation relativement complète et
vous me montrez par la même occasion
vous avez très bien compris ce qu'était
le mouvement des plaques tectoniques
voilà bonne préparation n'hésitez pas à
me contacter par mail si vous avez des
difficultés et je vous souhaite un bon
travail
à bientôt